okay so this guy I mean this guy it
didn't really happen they thank God
didn't happen because this guy was like
a supermodel really good looking guy and
now I'm meeting this guy that was back
in Italy and I'm literally down the road
what are you wearing babe and he's
wearing something and this guy was so
ugly it was an old different person
right so you got catfished yeah I was
like sorry I cannot make it I just
literally run down the road see what men
go through every day
you will see me running down the road so
quick I was like I'm sorry I can't make
it running I was like speeding I was
like where are you I can see you going
somewhere I was like oh no that wasn't
me
it was so bad it was it was no it was
terrible
since then I was like never again
have you ever been on a dating app
how did that go
okay mixed I mean
you know it's you can put your hand in a
bag and take it out and you'll get a
different response all the time but the
last time I went on one I mean I was
dating this guy for a period of time but
friendzoned him quite quickly I mean we
didn't have
I wasn't attracted to him
and yeah there wasn't anything to him
he's a nice guy but just not for me but
you know I dated him for a period of
time but I mean one lesson that I
learned is don't friend zone them and if
they're not if they're just not how can
I say if you're not attracted to them
there's no point in being with them so
just just don't do it I mean I've
learned the hard way so yeah yeah
because I think sometimes it gives
people like next expectations well
they'll think like maybe someday and
you're like no never like never yeah and
and it kind of ends up hurting feelings
down the line because I would hate if
someone did that to me yeah not only
that like you know
from quite early on I could see there
was
um we're not very compatible you know I
was good for going out going out
different places and I think he wanted
company I think that was the main thing
really and what he said to me was that
you know he wasn't very lucky on the
dating website so that told me that
you know he couldn't really get what he
wanted so was I second best did that
make him more undesirable because no one
wanted him no I think it was I don't
care yeah no it was more that we didn't
have much in common we didn't have
things that like interests me there was
no chemistry like I've got friends I
don't need her yeah was he too nice
I don't think any guy's ever too nice I
would disagree with that I disagree too
because I I used to be too nice so I've
been there myself what made you too nice
though my mum my mum's one of the nicest
women I've ever met in my life but she
would never tell me that cold hard truth
so
[Music]
um
I had to learn the hard way and
a lot started to happen in my life in a
positive way
but I think a lot of nice guys
this is going off in a bit of a point
but they aren't as actually as nice as
they seem
and they are living lives of quiet
desperation so
you might think he's nice but actually
he could have some fire in him and he
needs something to wake that up
that's what I truly believe I think
because a lot of times you feel like
it's fake yeah if a guy's too nice
you're like what's the catch or or it's
it's like
I don't know how to put this but it's
like you you feel like they're kind of
they're scared to like actually go for
what they want so they're just like
chilling in the friend zone instead of
just like going for what they want and
it's like as girls we want the man to
lead and I think actually
from being a recovering nice guy if you
like for anyone that's watching this
that feels like you're in that position
just wanting to improve is the step in
the right direction like I think correct
me if I'm wrong wrong ladies
but a guy on an opportunity rectory is
it is attractive right he might not be
exactly where you want him to be
but if he's honest to your point and
he's on an upward rise Fair place you
mate you'll at least trying you know I
actually I have a question for the girls
would you guys prefer a guy
um
that is around your age but he's very
ambitious and he's going places or would
you rather have someone that's 10 15
years older and he's there someone
on my age and is going places okay so
what do you mean by he's there
um let's see career-wise so one guy has
a business he's successful one guy's
starting one and it could go either way
but he's very driven and you think you
think he's going somewhere it depends on
the they're both they're both marriage
minded both the same oh okay well the
older one then you'd pick the older why
um just because they have more
experience they're more wise and um
because they've had more experiences I
trust their ability to lead
um that's the main reason
yeah okay what why do you say no or the
younger one
for me it's like would be more on the
same page and that we can understand
each other a little bit more even though
if you if he's more of a leader I don't
mind because we're building something
together whereas if a guy is already
made it sometimes they kind of May
belittle you and just undermine you a
little bit and kind of control you
that's where the control could come in
to it as well as them being older as
well it's like therefore like they know
better than you so you don't really know
nothing whereas if you're some dating
somebody who's around the same age as
you is that you two are coming up
together and I'll say like a success
story for example like um
like nowadays women will go for a guy
that has money like okay that's their
preference by sometimes it's like guys
don't believe there's still women out
there that will go for a guy that's
still trying to make it as long as you
have ambition that is it if you're a guy
you don't have money and you have no
ambition then I can understand I
wouldn't really want to be with you
however if you have the ambition and the
drive and I can see that then why not by
all means we can make it together yeah
and you have something to back up that
ambition too yeah like yeah that that
makes sense yeah I think one of the
problems that I've got with that is that
women's if you are dating a guy who's
I must say if you're dating below okay
you're normally make him a project and
you you kind of a woman might want him
they'll see the vision of him being a
bus driver but really is a cleaner so
they work on that when really they
should be working on themselves
and that's the problem that I have with
that like I've got my goddaughter you
know she if I say to her oh she's now 34
34.
um I think you'll be suited to someone
who's 37. she thinks oh that's too much
of a big man and I'm thinking that's
ideal for you not the guy that you've
just you know left the guy that you're
not with who was kind of relatively your
age but you had to kind of work on him
to be the person that he is today yeah
that took a lot of working hard you know
like disappointment and now she's not
with him so at the end of the day for me
I actually want to meet someone at a
higher level I don't want um a come up I
can't I just don't think that it will
suit me basically I haven't got the time
or patience for that uh what about when
you were younger would you have had the
same answer
I think when I was younger I didn't know
what I know now today and what do you
know now
self-love is very important is key and
also what's key is
where do you want to go in five years
I mean do you just want to be a
girlfriend for 10 years how many how
many girlfriends do you think you want
to be why not you know think more
serious if you think serious about your
life you're going to get serious
outcomes to know what I mean yeah I
think I started old I started when I was
30. so I think dating seriously dating
dating going out with men first
experience 30. now if I knew what I know
now
it would be different you know I would
have married I wouldn't have divorced I
would have had my kids you know so it
would have been different when did you
get divorced I'm not divorced I thought
you said you would have gotten to you
wouldn't I wouldn't have got divorced
but you wouldn't have gotten divorced
yeah so I said when did you get divorced
I didn't I haven't I what I what I said
was that I would not have been divorced
because I think I had quite Traditional
Values back then I wanted to be married
I wanted kids that kind of thing I think
I understand like I don't I don't think
that I would think you would you know if
you had a different mind so you would
have probably married like and you would
be divorced by now what I meant was that
I would have married and that would have
been it I wouldn't have been thinking
about divorce because sometimes when
people get into relationships they think
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible